Elon Musk considers bringing Alex Jones
back to X will run a poll to decide so
here's what happens we uh we have Tucker
Carlson drop his interview with Alex
Jones the quartering tweets think about
how much letting Alex Jones back on X
would make the machine rage Elon Musk
it's time Elon responds we'll consider
in general since this platform aspires
to be the global Town Square permanent
bans should be extremely rare also if he
does say something false on this
platform then Community notes will
correct him whereas that would not be
the case elsewhere and then he says
let's hold a poll so this could be it I
think uh I I I think with this boycott
the attack against Elon Musk and X which
is clearly nonsensical uh Elon earlier
was tweeting at Disney because Instagram
and M uh Instagram and Facebook meta
companies were sued by the New Mexico AG